this is very different movie than any of
the other sheep worked up for how does
directing dance sequences and musical
numbers compare with doing fight scenes
and action sequences well actually the
first few productions I ever did as I
started on music videos with music
videos so I'm more familiar with the
world actually you might think and even
I've forgotten that actually but I was
surprised when I was making pretty
comfortable with this and I wasn't
intimidated by the old traditional
theatrical musical component which even
I thought I would have been but then I
remembered somehow sounds very familiar
and that's why glad you forget because
in kind I feel that's less embarrassed I
know that has a lot in common with
characters from some other movies like
lock stock and snatch how do you think
he might fit in in those two movies uh
uh well I would have thought rather well
I mean it's a different world right the
characters essentially the same I
suppose that's a notable part while I
was interested in the movie is that had
had enough familiar not familiar ground
there and also got five kids so it means
that all as I watch his kind of family
movies anyway so but it was question of
fusing those two worlds but that's
principally why was it wanted to make it
okay opposite question how many wishes
do you think Jason Statham would get out
of the genie that's got a funny
I suppose things
I imagine he imagined he managed to
squeeze a few out what did you learn
from early test screenings that perhaps
impacted the the final cut of this film
I don't think any actually I think we
but the useful thing about having making
a film that's already been made before
as you know works so so we had the
advantage of you know DNA that we know
works so we only had one test screening
I think yeah I think you just confirmed
what we already knew any
okay we're what particular sequence or
song or element of the original film
were you most looking forward to
adapting for this version well curiously
I can only remember the last thing I did
right so Jamal Sims he was my
choreographer he he constructed a dance
sequence at the end which I have to tell
you I I adored and it still leaves me
with a smile on my face at the end so
not only did you finish the story about
there's a little dart sequence at the
end it just leaves me feeling uncynical
about the world were you a Disney fan as
a kid yeah I was but if there was a
title able to be delighted
that's so if well cuz it was kind of
familiar right I mean I know why because
I think is he is the only street cutter
kid in like a Disney lexicon nothing
isn't I'm pretty sure yeah unless you
count Oliver and Oliver and company
right so anyway that was the principal
reason so I felt comfortable there
also because I'm just up to me eyeballs
in family movies anyway because the kids
hmm